so
hello
the coronavirus continues to spread
rapidly
across europe we need a safe and
effective vaccine to end this pandemic
a few days after our contract with
biontech
and pfizer i'm happy to announce a new
agreement
tomorrow we will authorize a new
contract to secure
another covet 19 vaccines vaccine for
europeans
this contract allows us to buy up to
405 million doses
of a vaccine produced by the european
company curvac
earlier this year we have provided
funding to kurovac together with the
european investment bank
we did that to support the development
of these vaccines and now
progress is tangible if the vaccine has
proven
safe and effective against covet 19
every member state will receive the
vaccine
at the same time on a pro-rata basis
and under the same conditions this
is the fifth contract with the
pharmaceutical company
for our covet 19 vaccine portfolio
and we are working on a sixth one
with moderna we have already concluded
exploratory talks with moderna
we hope to finalize the contract soon
we do not know at this stage which
vaccine will end up being
safe and effective the european
medicines agency
emma will authorize them only after a
robust
assessment and this is why we need to
have a broad
portfolio of vaccines based on very
different technologies
in parallel we are working with covax
to provide access to vaccines for low
and middle income countries
thus we want to ensure that all have
access rapidly to safe and effective
vaccines thank you very much
[Music]
you